In George Orwell's 1984,
the government is trying
to force Britain,
or rather, "Airstrip One",
to use Newspeak:
a constructed language that
would end "thought-crime".
The goal, so the story goes,
is to make it impossible
to form ideas that could
challenge the ruling Party
by taking away the words
to think them with.
Linguists often cringe when
they hear people talk about
the idea that the language you speak
determines how you can think.
Because it's… well, it's
not really a thing.
It's been called the
"Sapir-Whorf Hypothesis",
because it's associated with
Benjamin Lee Whorf,
an early 20th century linguist,
and his mentor, Edward Sapir.
They weren't the first, the last,
or the loudest linguists to
ask the question, and they never
wrote anything even close
to a hypothesis about it together.
They wondered how language
could impact thought,
and vice versa,
but no more than that.
The concept is known as
linguistic determinism
in its strong form,
and linguistic relativism
in its weak form.
Determinism, the "strong" version,
is a popular trope in fiction,
particularly science fiction.
Which is where it belongs!
The film Arrival made it a major
plot point and actually name-checked it.
"If you immerse yourself into
a foreign language, that you
"can actually rewire your brain?"
"The Sapir-Whorf Hypothesis."
"Hmm."
The short story it's based on is much better.
Linguistic determinism is not taken very
seriously by the linguistics community,
as it's easily disprovable.
Either by attending a Philosophy 101 course,
or just thinking about the phrase,
"I wish I could find the words
to explain how I feel."
But the weak form, linguistic relativism,
is much more broadly accepted.
It is a difficult and messy thing
to test for and prove, though.
You can find a lot of people
claiming that the Russian language
has no word for "privacy",
because the concept of 'privacy' isn't
part of traditional Russian culture?
That might be true,
I'm not Russian,
I couldn't tell you,
but that wouldn't be language
limiting the way you think,
that would be language
reflecting the way you think.
There have been studies
that show things like:
German speakers, whose language
says that 'key' is 'masculine',
are more likely to describe a key
as 'jagged', 'rough', and 'hard',
whereas Spanish speakers,
where 'key' is 'feminine',
would be more likely to use
'golden' or 'intricate'.
I've referred to that
exact study here in the past.
But when other researchers tried
to replicate that study,
they didn't find the same result,
which is something that
keeps happening
across psychology
and other fields.
And besides, it's very difficult
to tease apart
the impacts of your culture and
the impacts of your language.
Even if that result is true,
which it's probably not…
is the gendered language the cause,
or the effect?
There are some clear impacts on how
different languages, not cultures,
affect the brain.
For example, our hearing tunes
into the phonology, the sounds,
of the languages we speak.
In Hindi, for example,
[tʰal] and [tal]
are two different words,
platter and rhythm,
because [tʰ] and [t] are considered
different sounds,
based on the aspiration,
that air that comes out.
That's not a cultural value,
that's not ideology,
it's not passed down
deliberately to children.
That's just language.
If you speak a language
with that distinction,
your brain will hear it
automatically and unconsciously.
And if you don't, you have to try
to actively listen for it.
That's a pretty clear way that
languages impact thought.
But that doesn't feel close enough
to the science fiction, does it?
It's not like it's changing your
understanding of the world.
Science fiction wants the
language you speak
to affect the categories
in your head,
the way you understand the world,
particularly for abstract concepts,
rather than actual physical things.
So what about emotions?
Emotions do get categorized
in different ways by different humans
all over the world.
In English, we can use the same word
for two different feelings.
If someone says "I'm sad",
do they mean
"crying in the corner"
or "depressed, tired,
and staying in bed"?
Those are both sad
in the same way that the sky
and the ocean are both blue.
But even if a child
only knows the word "sad",
they've not heard of "despondent'
or 'listless' or 'morose' or 'ennui',
well, the underlying emotions
are still different,
they can still tell whether someone's
grieving the devastating loss of
their cartoonishly large lollipop
or whether they're just tired
and generally down.
Having the different words is really
helpful for expressing yourself,
but they don't determine
your ability to feel emotions.
And Ancient Greek had a
lot of words for love:
in English those are all
basically translated as 'love'
with a lot of extra notes,
but even though we only have
one basic word
to explain all those
feelings and emotions,
we still experience them,
and we can communicate them
without knowing Ancient Greek.
It just takes a few more words.
Until recently, English did not
have a word for
"feeling joy at
someone else's misfortune",
but we still definitely
experienced it
before we borrowed
"schadenfreude" from German.
So the simple answer
to the question is: no.
Not really. It might change how
you listen to sounds,
it might make some things
easier to explain,
but the idea that
you can stop people
bringing down the government
by changing their language is,
thankfully, just fiction.
And if you want even more linguistics,
my co-author Gretchen McCulloch
has a podcast called
"Lingthusiasm".
The link is on screen
and in the description.